all right let's get into emails for the
week remember you can email info
davidpakman.com if you have something to
say please use the email address
sparingly because uh if you use it a lot
your emails will get auto flagged into
the trash unfortunately i was actually
we were updating our system uh the other
day
and um we actually have close to a
hundred different people that email us
so much that their emails are just being
auto filtered so don't be one of those
folks send an occasional message
if you have something to say first one
actually comes from from facebook and
says could you be any more delusional
you constantly spew propaganda and
claims that are easily disprove easily
proven false
then you never retract you're a pathetic
joke i have to congratulate this person
um it seems almost like a legal
requirement that if you send right wing
hate mail you mix up your and the
contraction for you are y o u apostrophe
re this person actually got the right
your here and they really should be
commended for that now everything else
they say is of course untrue they don't
cite anything that i was wrong about or
correct me they're also wrong that we
never retract in fact when i'm made
aware
that uh we got something wrong on the
show
i will usually open the following show
and actually just say hey i got
something wrong yesterday and here's
what it was i apologize here's what uh
here's what it is
um okay next one from chris chris says
vaccine hesitancy in other countries
david sur i've recently read there is
vaccine hesitancy in other parts of the
world i realize that in america
most of the hesitancy is politically
based what is your opinion of this
phenomenon in other countries
love your show listen daily paid
subscriber keep up the great work
it's different in different countries
we've talked about vaccine hesitancy for
example in france versus in italy
and in other countries as well in in
some places it is political
as influenced by what's going on in the
united states so there are other
countries where folks have been
convinced by the rantings of american
right-wingers about it's authoritarian
it's oppressive all of this different
stuff and they've just sort of gone with
that there's also a pretty sizable
anti-big pharma
sentiment in in some other countries
that drives vaccine hesitancy and you
know in the united states we talked
about this with nicolas christakis two
weeks ago
before the covet vaccines in the united
states you had anti-vaxx on the left and
you also had it on the right
the left-wing anti-vaxx tended to be
motivated by distrust of big pharma i
don't trust big corporations the
anti-vax on the right
tended to be dominated by i don't trust
the government meaning if a school
requires my kid to be vaccinated i don't
trust that or whatever the case may be
and so you had a kind of crossover of
anti-vaxx from left and right in the
united states coveted anti-vaxx is
overwhelmingly right-wing there it's it
still exists on the left
uh jordan clepper recently did some
interesting interviews with some folks
in uh at the la area and they don't seem
particularly right-wing they seem more
of distrustful of vaccines along the
sort of like reiki homeopathy herbs type
thing which is more more of a left-wing
thing and you see that more in other
countries as well you see that in italy
uh you see that in france as well so the
answer to what drives anti-vax in other
countries is it depends on which country
and uh there's a little bit of
everything floating around
a next email came from pp
who says hey david i was wondering if
you could shed some light on this new
fouchy bill gates email thread that alex
jones and glenn beck are saying is a
smoking gun
that covid was a product of gain of
function research and then
them along with moderna had the vaccine
created six months before the virus came
out
and released it on purpose
and all kind of wacky stuff yeah i can't
comment unfortunately i can't shed any
light into that
that sounds like five or six different
conspiracy theories
blended together into a smoothie of
sorts
and i have no idea how they all come
together i've never even heard of them
put together into one conspiracy like
that one thing i think uh is is
important to consider
is
if the conspiracy is so confusing
that you can't even really come up with
plausible motive linking all of these
groups together like as i've said many
times before
finding motive alone does not prove a
conspiracy theory but if you can't even
find motive or understand it or even
really understand what the theory is be
skeptical of the people that are telling
you that this is the way that things are
austin rhoden
about trump's weird sniff
and says david i haven't heard you bring
this up yet but another one of trump's
big tells is that sniff thing he does
after almost every sentence very
annoying and a pretty good indicator
he's spinning another yarn keep it up
bud i i've never seen the trump sniffing
as a signal that he's lying
because he sniffs almost all the time
now you might say well yeah but david
he's lying almost all the time but even
when he says inconsequential things i
see the the sniff more of like as a tick
or maybe something related to medication
he takes or something like that and it
is notable he'll say uh you know i got
home and melania said to me sir you were
on tv
and then there there's the sniff there
um for me it's less about lying it just
seems to be a verbal thing that trump
does maybe maybe related to medication
but it never seems specifically like a
lie signal the big lie signals i've
identified are he claims someone called
him sir
like when he the infamous story the one
that's the obvious lie when he said you
know when i came into office a general
came to me and said sir we have no
ammunition we're out of bullets from
obama and i told him well let's buy more
like that story couldn't have happened
that's a lie the other one is he says
and it's really a shame you know he'll
say
well
a hundred thousand dead people voted and
they took uh they took michigan and
pennsylvania and arizona from me and
it's really a shame it's really a shame
that's a sign that he's lying and then
the other one is and it should never
happen again or we can't let it happen
again they they took the election with
an insurrection on november 3rd and we
can't let it happen again he's lying
when he uses that one and also many many
others but the sniff one for me uh that
that's a different category leslie wrote
in with a non-political question this is
actually a really good question
leslie says hey david love the show
would appreciate your input
um if a group of people go on vacation
together would you split the cost of the
vacation rental per person
or per bedroom
i've always subscribed to per person but
have discovered recently a friend uses
the per bedroom calculation when divided
per bedroom the single friend pays more
for their room than the couple in my
mind all other parts of the rental home
and its amenities would be considered
equal so why not the bedrooms in your
opinion which is correct
you could really go either way with this
you know if when let's imagine not a
vacation rental but let's imagine an
apartment right because at a vacation
rental you don't usually pay for
electricity water utilities etc if
you're renting an apartment and you've
got a couple sharing a room and then a
single person sharing a room it seems
reasonable to me
that you would say okay
in terms of space we have a room
and you have a room so that would be
split equally even though it's two
people versus one but you would adjust
for the fact that utilities are going to
be higher for the two people and how i
do that how you do that i don't know you
say well we will pay i guess you just
say if the utilities are paid separately
we'll pay two thirds of the utilities
but half of the rent that seems
reasonable mathematically on a vacation
i think i would take a totally different
approach quite frankly and it's who
proposes it and honestly who makes more
money uh you know there's a lot of
situations i've been in where it's sort
of like
if someone if someone is financially
better off and says i'm the one renting
i'm renting this house either way come
on and you know give me throw me a
hundred bucks or you know whatever the
case may be
that's often the way it actually goes
less than on a per person or per bedroom
basis but as a general thing on a on a
vacation rental
i lean heavily on per bedroom
per bedroom let me know what you think
evan wrote in and says conservative
hypocrisy
about natural immunity
david sir i see many conservatives and
vaccine skeptics espousing the use of
monoclonal antibodies to treat covid
such as dennis prager or your more
recent segment on joe rogan supporting
it this seems very counter-intuitive to
their baseless theory that so-called
natural immunity is better than vaccine
immunity
is it not hypocritical that they are so
against a vaccine that will strengthen
the immune system against covid but are
willing to take a different drug that
also strengthens your immune system
against covet i understand the drugs and
their effects are different but from
their perspective of so-called natural
immunity they are still unnatural
substances you're putting into your body
to fight off off the virus of course
yeah monoclonal antibodies listen when
they say they don't trust the vaccine
but they trust the antibodies the pfizer
vaccine is now fully approved whereas
the antibodies are only approved via
emergency use so it's a lower standard
number two when they say i don't trust
big pharma
the the monoclonal antibodies are also
made by big pharma and they are far more
profitable and i think about 2 000 per
treatment than you know a 15 to 30
vaccine so the money argument also
doesn't make sense and yes in a sense
you were you were generating immunity
not simply by fighting off the virus
but
via the integration
of other antibodies that you didn't
create into your body so it is
absolutely hypocritical
along those lines as well very very good
point and
what's the answer the answer is they
don't actually care they're just against
the vaccine because all the arguments
they make against it fall apart when you
see that they're doing
monoclonal antibodies or other big
pharma treatments or things that are not
actually fda approved either
james wrote in and says congressman
nunes was on the evening edit on fox and
my job practically dropped they were
complaining about hunter biden making
money with china and now he shouldn't be
allowed to fly on air force one and he
was trading with the enemy these are the
same people that had no problem with the
kushners making hundreds of millions of
dollars while working in the white house
and ivanka being granted trademarks by
the chinese government
my advice on this hunter biden stuff is
do not even engage just just ignore it
like i don't i don't really know what
they're saying now about hunter i know
some right-wingers write to me and say
david you should be talking about hunter
hunter has no involvement with the biden
administration and of course all of the
criticisms of hunter
apply i i well maybe not all but close
to all of the criticisms of hunter apply
certainly to jared and ivanka at minimum
um if not also to don jr and eric trump
they don't apply to baron i guess that's
that would be the exception and tiffany
everybody forgets about yeah just i
wouldn't even pay attention quite
frankly
uh zach from orlando has a crazy story
um and says
just wanted to share a story i overheard
while at the office yesterday for
context i work in orlando and
occasionally have to visit the corporate
office in tampa when i arrived i
overheard our coo and cfo complaining
about the traffic on i-4 and how it's
all part of biden's america you see
david according to these highly overpaid
executives ever since biden got into
office nobody wants to work since nobody
wants to work
there's less truck drivers on the road
that would be fewer since there's fewer
truck drivers on the road trucking
companies have to hire people with less
experience although i thought nobody
wanted to work and finally since there
are more inexperienced truck drivers on
the road there's more traffic
ah
because by virtue of being less
experienced they drive more slowly i
guess makes sense right couldn't
possibly have anything to do with our
crumbling infrastructure poor public
transit options etc nope all biden's
fault yeah that's that's pretty full on
i mean that that that's wackier
it's so specific
and it's sort of a problem how do i even
say it's an explanation in search of a
problem sort of i don't even know how to
say it fully uh but that's really wacky
and zach i'm really sorry that you're
working around that uh that that kind of
nonsense hopefully it's not like that
every day
a thanks for all of your emails you can
send yours to info
davidpakman.com
and we've got a great bonus show planned
for you today you can sign up at
joinpacman.com
and otherwise we'll be back with you on
monday